salut à tous vous écoutez envergure
voici notre format spécial Victor web
bagnama un joueur exceptionnel podcast
exceptionnel une fois par mois vous avez
l'habitude maintenant on suit la
progression du meilleur prospect
français de l'histoire et oui avec un
maximum de précisions ça c'est notre
pâte la pâte envergure maximum de
détails et puis on parle aussi quand
même de ceux qui seront de sa classe de
draft de sa génération en quelque sorte
parce que la draft 2023 c'est Victor et
les autres le père aimait Hugo il prenne
Lama Victor ce fils dont le destin
d'effraya les gazettes avec pour ce
troisième épisode
[Musique]
comment vas-tu
sont très bien toi ça va très bien je
suis en pleine forme mois de décembre
mercredi 7 décembre d'ailleurs pour
l'enregistrement on le note mercredi 7
décembre il est de retour pour l'épisode
3 de Victor et les autres FD comment
vas-tu
ça va ça va très bien merci de
l'invitation toujours un plaisir en plus
c'est plus une invitation c'est la
première fois c'est plus une invitation
quand tu es malade
c'est plus invité là avec ben je suis un
peu je suis un peu intimidé je te cache
on a pris ton rendez-vous pour le
tatouage envergure
c'est un tatouage avec avec
tribberg sur sur le biceps on va choisir
pour toi
alors on connaît le principe d'abord
Victor on parle des news rapidement puis
on va se focus se concentrer sur un
aspect de son jeu aujourd'hui on va se
concentrer sur le handle donc la
dextérité le dribble notre deuxième
partie et ben on parle des autres donc
ce soir la sensation de ce début de
saison NCIS j'ai nommé Brandon Miller et
puis la troisième partie c'est en
anglais toujours et c'est avec un invité
même s'il est français ce coup-ci Pascal
giberner il a eu la chance de passer une
journée avec Victor pour écrire
l'article qui est consacré à web banyama
dans le magazine américain slam
alors les amis on est heureux on est
parti on commence avec l'actu de Victor
one banyama ça faisait longtemps que
Victor et que les Metz n'avaient pas
perdu un match ça a été fait lors de la
dernière journée de championnat à Roanne
donc à Vacheresse
contre la chorale FD tu as vu le match
qu'est-ce qui est intéressant de noter
donc chez Victor Victor en difficulté
d'habitude on le voyait gagner alors la
victoire qui prend 30 points je crois
dans la gueule qu'est-ce que ça donne
ouais Victor qui prend 30 points dans la
gueule Victor qui avait l'air
physiquement un peu à moindrée il y
avait des quelques bruits de couloirs
qui disait qu'il était malade en tout
cas voilà il a pris deux fautes
rapidement au premier carton une
troisième au deuxième carton un peu
moins
laver la rampe au moins concernée en
première mi-temps en deuxième mi-temps
il a il a fait un très bon début de
troisième il a repris un peu les choses
en main avec une production qui était
vraiment mieux et puis ensuite voilà le
plan anti-webanyama de Jean-Denis sous
les qui a bien fonctionné et puis voilà
l'éclat un peu d'adresse du côté droit
et à partir de ce moment-là c'était
compliqué pour pour les messes de
revenir mais mais ouais sûrement le
match le plus compliqué pour l'instant
d'Oma cette saison
pas Henry suite avec son tir mais ça on
avait déjà eu on avait déjà vu d'autres
matchs où il était pas en Russie avec
son style mais il l'avait notable enfin
il avait pu peser sur le match mais là
vraiment physiquement un petit peu moins
bien ce qui fait que notamment en
défense c'était c'était moins
impressionnant que d'habitude ben
qu'est-ce qui t'a marqué toi dans les
performances récentes de Victor one
byama donc notre dernier podcasts datant
de début novembre le dernier match que
j'ai regardé c'était contrefos-sur-mer
la semaine dernière
et
honnêtement
c'est les performances se suivent se
sont suivis au niveau du mois de
novembre mais ce sont rassemblés un peu
une trentaine de points une dizaine de
rebonds une une commande du jeu qui est
à peu près absolu une capacité à se
rendre au cercle à naviguer dans le
trafic qui grandit de match en match une
confiance qui grandit de match en match
aussi c'est
c'est
à peu près à l'heure des lancer le plus
difficile à réussir au basket qui
rentrent de mieux en mieux
je trouve que dans ces dernières
performances
il joue un peu comme un joueur de
Touquet qui aurait été inventé qu'on
aurait mis de l'argent dessus si les
gens qui jouent à Touquet savent de quoi
je parle on fait un joueur en mode my
player on met 20 ou 30 dollars dessus
puis on domine c'est un peu à ça que
j'ai pensé en regardant victoriama jouer
je trouve que ce qui est la chose qui me
fait peur présentement à partir de
maintenant j'ai pas regardé Roanne mais
je vais regarder après ce podcast ça
m'intéresse de le voir dans une dans une
cause perdante mais j'ai juste peur
qu'on se mette à suranaliser
Victor à partir de maintenant puis à
faire des montagnes à partir de
problèmes qui vont se corriger même
c'est le risque alors on va essayer de
pas tomber dedans dans ce podcast mais
le but c'est quand même de l'analyser
précisément je voulais juste revenir
hors antenne comme on dit de à la radio
avant d'enregistrer de commencer à
enregistrer on discutait et tu me disais
que toi toi agent Victor ne jouera plus
de la saison c'est ça que tu m'as dit
ouais ben tu étais le conseil de
100% parce que côté draft côté côté
chose à gagner pour Victor Wayne banama
avec ce qui est démontré là c'est fait
le numéro 1 c'est à lui le numéro 1
c'est à lui de le perdre puis il va
seulement le perdre avec une blessure
majeure c'est quelque chose qui produit
cette année présentement ce qui fait
selon moi c'est une c'est une tournée
promotionnelle pour mousser sa carrière
NBA puis je crois qu'il y a des intérêts
qui sont beaucoup plus gros que son
agent et que son club là je crois NBA
essaie de l'entourer de le chouchouter
pour en faire un des prochains visages
de la Ligue parce que s'il arrêtait de
jouer demain matin se concentrerait sur
la draft il y a pas une équipe qui y
passerait deux fois avant de rester
premier FB
je pense qu'on est même surpris de
toujours le voir sur le terrain
aujourd'hui
en début de saison quand il avait signé
au Metz je pense qu'on se disait tous
que voilà il allait jouer cinq six
matchs et puis qu'il allait être arrêté
au mois de novembre le voir toujours
jouer autant puis que hier il faut quand
même dire qu'ils prennent qu'ils
prennent 30 points contre Road mais il
est toujours sur le terrain au 4e carton
voilà il y a pas j'ai pas l'impression
qu'il y a une entreprise de de
conservation de Victor Hugo ce qui est
vraiment soit prenant pour le coup je
suis agréable surpris parce que ça m'est
quand même de la lumière sur le
championnat français sur nos autres
joueurs que ce soit des jeunes joueurs
ou des joueurs plus expérimentés mais ça
ça donne de l'audience ça donne du monde
dans les salles et puis du côté du
basket français c'est positif si Victor
peut faire ça sans mettre en
péril son avenir c'est tout et après bon
ce que je te répondais ben mais je vais
le redire il y a quand même le côté être
le leader d'une équipe ce qu'il n'a pas
beaucoup pété dans le monde pro et qu'il
est en train d'expérimenter maintenant
messieurs on passe avec à la précision
j'allais dire j'ai dit qu'on allait
qu'on allait traiter ce soir le thème du
handle de la dextérité du dribble de
Victor alors où on en est de sa
progression là-dessus c'est pas un de
ces grands points forts évidemment
qu'est-ce qu'il qu'est-ce qui s'est fait
qu'est-ce qu'il ne sait pas faire je
commence avec toi FD alors déjà je pense
je l'avais déjà dit pour la défense la
dernière fois
le dribble à sa taille c'est déjà du
bonus c'est pas quelque chose qu'on peut
attendre légitimement du pro d'un
prospect normal mais comme voilà là je
pense que c'est assez clair pour tout le
monde c'est notre troisième épisode de
la série Victor n'est pas un prospect
normal on ne peut pas voilà on a des
attentes démesurées par rapport à lui
mais il faut quand même garder en tête
que dribbler pour quelqu'un qui est plus
de mettre 23 aussi long soit ses bras
c'est pas forcément quelque chose de
naturel c'est pas quelque chose de pas
forcément quelque chose qui peut être
fait de
un très haut niveau
tout simplement parce que voilà la balle
est en l'air beaucoup plus longtemps
que voilà malgré ses capacités
ses capacités physiques il a quand même
un centre de gravité qui est quand même
assez haut et donc forcément la balle
reste en l'air pendant longtemps pendant
ces dribbles donc ça c'est déjà un point
de vue le vulnérabilité qui dont il faut
parler au début
ce qui fait que
face à une grosse pression
son dribbles
étant difficulté
il y a il y a beaucoup de situations où
il se retrouve face à des gardes qui ont
qui après un switch sur des écrans et
c'est là où il a le plus de difficultés
à les battre par le dribble parce qu'ils
sont capables de défendre très proche de
lui et de lui mettre la pression et il
est à ce moment-là obligé de reculer
mais il faut quand même parler de sa
qualité de dextérité qui lui permet
surtout sur des sites steps sur des sur
des mouvements un seul dribble ou à
pouvoir se décaler avec une très longue
envergure de créer un décalage qui est
important mais sur les enchaînements de
dribble
sur sur les moments où il va devoir
poser la balle pendant plusieurs fois
d'affilée face à une pression c'est des
situations pour l'instant il est pas
encore tout à fait à l'aise ben
qu'est-ce que tu peux ajouter sur sur ce
diagnostic du dribble de Victor Wemba
nyama et je vais mettre en contexte un
petit peu qu'est-ce qui devra savoir
faire en NBA en fait le leader d'une
grosse équipe qui ne sait pas encore
faire
c'est très complet comme analyse de FD
je rajouterais peut-être que j'aime
beaucoup
ces changements de direction sont
dribbles avec ses changements de
direction surtout lorsqu'ils au panier
il se met à protéger le ballon et là il
va attendre la prise à deux il va être
capable de passer en deux joueurs ça
j'apprécie beaucoup ça chez lui je crois
que c'est une bonne utilisation de son
physique et une bonne
un bon travail à l'intérieur de ses
limites fait que ça j'aime ça mais oui
il faut falloir qu'on module nos
attentes par rapport au dribble de
Victor je crois pas qu'il sera devenu un
grand dribbleur juste par faute de
logistique qui est trop grand pour ça
mais qu'est-ce qui va lui manquer pour
être le leader de son équipe
écoute je sais pas j'ai jamais j'ai
jamais entendu parler très très
longtemps Victoria
mettre son équipe sur ses épaules et
trouver des manières de gagner et de
mettre ces parlais du dribble je parlais
vraiment
tu vois est-ce qu'on peut espérer un
développement à un dribble à la Kevin
Durant qui est pas aussi grand que je
l'entends bien mais qui est grand quand
même et qui parvient à dribbler près du
sol il y arrive il pose pas beaucoup de
dribbles en soi Kevin Durant qui arrive
quand même ouais puis capable de créer
pour lui-même je crois que ça serait un
peu
utopique de croire ça je me suis déjà
trompé mais je dirais Kevin Durant on
parle de niveau d'agilité et de timing
qui est absolument
phénoménal que Kevin agilité un timing à
6-10 et demi qui est meilleur que celui
de des gardes de la cc2c3 donc je sais
pas si on peut mettre la barre là mais
je crois que apprendre à travailler à
l'intérieur de apprendre à savoir quand
tu es son dribble à savoir quand repérer
ses coéquipiers alors de prise à deux je
crois que ça va maximiser un peu
ces pochettes d'opportunités ça va le
savoir faire une arme qui va faire en
sorte que les prises à deux vont être
une pour être une
offre pas une décision si facile pour
les équipes adverses FD quelle arme est
importante à développer pour lui au
niveau du dribble là avant d'arriver en
NBA quel
sur quelle situation précise on peut se
dire tiens s'il arrive à faire ça ça va
lui faire ça va lui débloquer pas mal de
situations je pense sur des situations
où il reçoit la balle postaux ou post
bas et il se met face à l'attaquant
enfin face aux défenseurs pardon ça va
être important pour lui surtout de
pouvoir allier à la fois la qualité de
dribble et l'utilisation de son épaule
en fait pour pouvoir créer se créer un
espace traditionnel séparation qui est
capable déjà d'utiliser parce qu'il peut
tirer au dessus de n'importe qui mais
aussi parce qu'il peut l'ajouter à son
répertoire de step back qu'il a déjà mis
distance notamment ben tu vois un truc à
ajouter au niveau du répertoire que ce
soit face au cercle ou d'eau au Cercle
d'ailleurs
non j'ai juste peur de tomber un peu
dans l'idéaliste me dire devrait ajouter
s'il devrait ajouter ça il devrait
ajouter ça je pense que que le dribble
justement il devrait m'apprendre un peu
à
gérer les situations de risque dans le
fond je crois que je crois que peut-être
développer un dribble à la Kevin Durant
justement sur une question d'année
peut-être deux trois ans puis
présentement juste de garder le ballon
en sécurité puis FD à ne pas l'opposé
une bonne situation dans les situations
au poste haut lorsqu'il est face à face
parce que au poste haut lorsqu'il
post-up ça va il est capable de s'en
sortir mais face à face là on parle ça
devient des épreuves de force souvent
avec des gars qui sont plus petits que
lui qui ont un centre de gravité plus
bas et là ça devient plus difficile mais
alors à quel
grand un peu dribbleur on pourrait on
pourrait espérer
comparaison on peut espérer au niveau du
dribble quelle évolution peut espérer
soit des joueurs passés ou actuels je
vais je vais être nul ici et je vais
être très anticasting je vais très très
Antibes je ne vois pas de comparaison
pour l'instant je crois que Victor
benyama est un
prospecte tellement unique que j'ai de
la difficulté je parle pas de la je
parle je parle pas de la comparaison sur
le joueur global évidemment du dribble
même je sais pas je pense moi dans ma
tête j'ai des gens qui ont un peu
développé leur dribble type jarenj
Jackson
tu vois ce genre de gars quoi j'ai rien
Jackson c'est pas con j'ai rien Jackson
c'est pas con je déteste pas je déteste
pas la comparaison
le fan des mix
en moi a quelques situations en tête de
cristal sportsdis prix
avant qu'il fasse les croiser où il
était quand même beaucoup plus mobile et
où il avait pu prendre quelques pick and
roll à New York avec la balle en main
le dribble était quand même très très
SketchUp dans ce temps-là c'était très
très STIF ouais c'était très STIF mais
il arrivait à faire quelques
enchaînements
crossover dribble dans le dos steak back
absolument ouais parce que Victor fait
parce que Victor fait des gens en fait
oui oui absolument
messieurs je crois que nous avons
terminé de parler de Victor en tout cas
de son dribble c'était notre focus on
vous invite à écouter les épisodes
précédents si vous voulez les
portrait complet en fait sera fait avec
la somme des épisodes c'est l'heure de
parler des autres et oui puisque ça
s'appelle Victor et les autres parlons
des autres
les autres c'est Brandon Miller joueur
d'Alabama alors pourquoi c'est le buzz
du moment parce que bah il a fait des
stats assez extraordinaires il shootent
après 40% à 3 points sur beaucoup de
tentatives il est grand il a un corps
qui paraît tout à fait viable avec les
modèles qu'on a dédiés NBA aujourd'hui
maintenant voilà aujourd'hui on va on va
on va se demander si il mérite un top 5
il mérit un top 10 très rapidement mais
surtout on va vous le présenter puisque
c'est un des noms dont vous allez
entendre parler si vous intéressez un
peu à la draft et à ceux qui
accompagneront qui seront dans la Green
Room avec Victor wembanyama au mois de
juin lors de l'annonce de cette draft
2023 ben est-ce que tu peux me faire un
portrait rapide un rapide portrait de
Brandon Miller 100% Brandon Miller et 6
donc ces deux mètres 6 91 kg
il vient du Tennessee c'est le fils d'un
ancien joueur de foot américain de
Alabama derrière Miller c'est pour ça
qu'il a signé avec Alabama il est un peu
plus vieux que la moyenne des
fraîchements ce qui est quand même
intéressant qui a gardé à l'esprit les
deux novembre 2002 il vient d'avoir 20
ans donc il va avoir 21 ans à l'année
prochaine au début de la saison NBA fait
que ça ça va peut-être jouer sur son App
stock tu l'as bien présenté un allié qui
beaucoup impressionné depuis le début de
l'année par sa capacité de tout faire un
peu c'est à dire de shooter premièrement
à trois points de d'attaquer le panier
je sais pas mais je sais même pas si au
panier il est chaud pour 50% mais on en
parlera plus tard à défendre aussi c'est
un défenseur qui a des qualités quand
même intéressantes moi je suis 100%
vendu mais je comprends pourquoi les
gens l'aiment je comprends pourquoi il
fait tourner les tags
dans quel contexte évolue-t-il FD notre
ami Brandon Miller quel est son rôle
dans son équipe d'Alabama alors à la
Bama on est chez Nate House qui est
voilà c'est le pronostic que j'ai depuis
pas mal de temps qui sera un jour coach
en NBA
voilà c'est mon c'est mon pari j'aime
beaucoup
il a un style très NBA c'est un style
voilà très NBA et du coup on voit
Brandon Miller dans des rôles vraiment
variés et ce qui est intéressant c'est
que c'est projetable dans un dans un
rôle en NBA
on le voit pour l'instant jouer post 3
post 4 en tout cas plutôt hors ballon la
plupart du temps puisque Nate house
comme à peu près pour le coup il est
très dans le classicisme NSIA il a
toujours un haut de garde
upper classman qui prennent beaucoup de
responsabilités
avant c'était chaque effort
mais du coup Brandon Miller a peu la
balle je vous surtout au ballon on le
voit sortir d'écran on le voit le
prendre des stagers on le voit aussi
poser des écrans ça qui est intéressant
on le voit poser des écrans puis sortir
puis flasher ou
prendre des cascades d'écran après
lui-même avoir posé un écran c'est c'est
intéressant la variété dans laquelle il
est utilisé mais par contre c'est là
qu'on a les flashs et je pense que c'est
pour ça que Brandon Miller fait tourner
autant de tête comme disait ben c'est
qu'on le voit aussi prendre des piqu'n
rolls Ball en main alors moins que que
les gardes qui ont beaucoup la balle
mais pour donner leur prend quand même
des écrans et et même des SPA une pick
and roll des des écrans un peu plus
complexes et on le voit faire des
lectures avancées ce qui est vraiment
intéressant donc voilà je j'ai hâte de
voir le reste de l'année sachant que
pour l'instant s'il continue à tirer à
50% à 3 points on risque de le voir
beaucoup beaucoup en sortie d'écran
effectivement
FD je commence par toi
est-ce que tu peux me donner une
impression de potentiel
évidemment on est au début de saison
donc on va pas prendre ça pour parole
d'évangile mais quand on entend des top
10 etc est-ce que tu vois en lui alors
visiblement oui un jour NBA oui mais
est-ce que tu vois en lui voilà un
potentiel qui qui pourra évoluer avec la
balle puisque pour être drafté dans le
top 10 en gros il faut quand même être
capable de porter le ballon et
efficacement potentiel top 10 oui
sûrement si
il est capable d'affiner au Cercle je
pense que comme Ben le disait pour
l'instant il est autour de 40% de fini
ce qui est ce qui est trop peu pour pour
l'imaginer vraiment dans ce rôle de
d'initiateur
d'initiateur de plus de 2 mètres qui est
forcément un rôle qui peut lui donner
une note de Top 12 quoi
le tir je pense va pas descendre j'ai du
mal à le voir rester aussi
mais je peux comprendre les gens qui le
mettent 10 je comprends je comprends
l'enflammade des gens qui top 5 pour
l'instant je pense que voilà je le
mettrai entre entre
7 et 10 en attendant de voir un petit
peu plus en défense et en attendant de
voir un petit peu plus en finition au
Cercle ok donc c'est quand même assez
aubaine tu es d'accord tu penses que ça
code va descendre que ce temps dit je
suis d'accord que ça code va descendre
je trouve que son tir est un peu bas
pour son pour sa grandeur il y a pas une
très grande élévation son point de son
point de lâcher est très bas et je
trouve aussi que ses capacités
d'initiateurs on en a fait un peu une
montagne
une espèce de tempête dans un verre
d'eau parce que oui il fait des belles
passes oui ça fonctionne mais dépasse
qui fait Brendan Melo c'est très très
risqué c'est-à-dire quand il fait des
hand tripass il fait ça dans le
dans le trafic quand il fait des bol de
passe dans le coin c'est des passes qui
sont cross-croûte donc c'est très risqué
puis ça passera pas NBA donc je voudrais
un petit peu de poudre aux yeux
présentement je crois avec la qualité de
son jeu et comme disait
comme disait FD la finition aussi va
jouer beaucoup parce que
chose intéressante je suis pas un gars
on parle souvent de la transition je ris
beaucoup des
des scouts qui disent ce joueur là est
excellent transition parce que les
joueurs sont tous bons en transition à
stage
extrêmement rapide extrêmement explosif
et c'est quand même fasse plus facile de
se correr quand il y a personne de
l'autre côté mais
Brandon Miller score 1.57 points en
transition ce qui est quand même assez
énorme ce qui
montre que la technique de finition est
pas le problème c'est la physicalité
c'est pas le meilleur athlète c'est pas
le gars le plus explosif il y a pas le
meilleur premier pas donc il va falloir
qu'ils gagnent du coffre j'ai
l'impression on a parlé avant l'émission
mais
son match contre North careylines si
vous voulez voir un match qui expose un
peu Bruel allez voir comment l'Equipe
black lui fait la peau pendant 48
minutes et vous allez comprendre un peu
qui a besoin de gagner un peu de coffre
d'être capable de créer de la séparation
pour lui-même de de de de de son propre
son propre espace parce que pour
l'instant il n'y arrive pas du tout et
c'est ce qui est à la ce qui est ici que
la racine de ces problèmes dans finition
donc ouais moi je pense qu'il peut-être
le triple plus que top 10 pour l'instant
pour moi je serai plus à l'aise de le
mettre 12 13e il y a des il y a des
alliés dans cette dark là que j'aime
plus que lui pour l'instant très bien
est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose sur lui
que vous n'avez pas dit et que vous
voulez dire de toute façon on en fera un
portrait plus détaillé de Brandon Miller
dans nos propres dans nos portraits
d'avant draft mais ce que vous voulez
dire quelque chose maintenant
je tiens juste à dire ne regardez pas
seulement le match contre Juventus parce
que sinon vous allez pas comprendre vous
allez pas comprendre pourquoi un
appareil pendant 10 minutes de ce gars
là voilà donc regardez il aura des aussi
d'autres oui vas-y ben samedi
Alabama je continue ça va être
[Musique]
Brandon Miller c'était notre avis sur
lui pour la deuxième partie de ce
podcast Victor et les autres la
troisième partie ça va se faire en
anglais alors je vous dis merci Ben et
FD à la prochaine merci Alex à bientôt à
bientôt on vous retrouve que ce soit sur
envergure.co que ce soit sur twitch avec
Hugues ou que ce soit dans les podcasts
abonnez-vous mettez-nous des notes on
vous adore tout de suite la troisième
partie c'est toujours Victor et les
autres mais cette fois c'est en anglais
allez on passe en anglais I will Pascal
giberne journaliste de New York fall out
time resent
magazine bonsoir Pascal
Victor
espèce
faut slam magazine everything you dead
note have the space to right news
[Musique]
of Levallois métropolitance
un des commandes
sometimes
on espère
[Musique]
scout Anderson twenty Frost before
agains
[Musique]
de vidéo coach
faute Victorine
[Musique]
Victor
Barcelone Christine
[Musique]
[Rires]
merci à tous et allez sur envergure.co
allez nous voir sur twitch sur YouTube
sur toutes les plateformes que vous
voulez
on vous embrasse à bientôt